Vladimir back-to-back victories for you
after a difficult first round accident
one might say tell us a bit about this
game did he surprise you Gregory with
this move C for this plan
with E5 already because as far as I know
he had never played this move before at
least I did not find any games so panov
I saw the panov and some Knight D2 stuff
so if I've I mean of course I I knew the
C4 move but I used to play this myself
but after H4 first H4 H5 is C4 there's
such yeah and this uh but I mean
somewhere around here and for example
detect C4 I decided to take I was I was
not I mean familiar with this position
very well and so many possibilities here
so I was just consuming my time here I
think that was the right choice and
perhaps he wasn't as familiar with it
either because 93 you know what I wanted
to do after Knight G3 and that's why why
I spent a lot of I just I wanted to
gamble with B5 here B5 okay yeah I I'm
not sure if this is correct because
there is A4 of course but some how I
thought that here before let's see E4 I
take on e4 and Knight F5 I think it is
interesting white definitely has
compensation but okay it's interesting
at least yeah this has been played by
the way so it wasn't a full gambling yes
it's serious possible yeah only that of
course after I had consumed this time I
decided okay it at least worth we're
trying this and you guys went into this
line it felt like
D3 so everywhere some some possibilities
Knight D4 and here also I was not sure
Knight D4 here there are some crazy
lines with Bishop E3 instead of castles
and that's it to check can go somewhere
I couldn't maybe D2 yeah and then if
takes on A1 here minimal even E6
possible but uh I don't know again very
complicated so I decided to avoid this
but I mean difficult to to understand
what is going on yeah and this was the
critical moment
that was possible actually here after
King E6 yeah and I think it's busy yeah
but somehow I played King E6 and only
that of course Knight D4 otherwise I
would have played but still it's equal I
mean yeah it should be equal yeah so
yeah King E6 at least if white does not
find kinetic B6 then he's already in
trouble I believe and that's exactly
what happened yeah F4 yeah and here okay
maybe Knight D4 is also strong I think
yeah 94 Rook d8 by far the best man best
Yeah Yeah by far the best move and this
end game is just completely losing I
think the engine is saying something
like minus three close to it no yeah of
course not because white lose the pawn
yes and so the mistake wise mistake came
when it was completely equal once we got
this position and then uh what Native
which net F4 was not best probably
instead of taking on uh
maybe yeah not necessary at all before
Knight F4 move uh before that before
yeah
just everywhere equal still uh yeah a
big victory for you against one of your
arrivals in this tournament who was
doing quite well before this one
gregoric idanov congratulations uh big
one tell us a bit about uh this
tournament what does it mean to you this
is only your second appearance
it's very pleasant and very good
organization here it's not very uh
common way in the US so it's usually
play two rounds a day yeah yeah this is
yeah that's because I wanted actually to
warm up before this tournament to play I
I was uh I mean considering playing in
Las Vegas but then yeah just twice a day
it's something already very difficult to
do and then I just I skipped this but
here no here I mean
everything is is is
a brilliant organization everything and
the only thing that you should you
should you should be considered of your
own play and this is what I actually
failed to do in the first round and uh
it's in general it's uh life is not fun
when you are blundering and I was
blundering something in a row some three
times in a row in that first game I
blundered uh but this is what happens
when you are out of practice
my last tournament before this one I
played in August last year Dubai open
yeah it's it's a long break yeah yeah
it's been a long break even though I I
did some job by my own coach a lot right
yeah yeah coach and they also work I
mean I I always almost maybe every day
unless something but still playing is
completely different yeah you just you
get out of form and after that difficult
today is about the Cadence of your moves
is about the decision making what do you
feel is the most I believe everything
everything calculation also I mean
you saw today I mean you should not
consume such much time in the opening
only because somehow you you don't feel
immediately what is going on yeah
calculations everything uh assessment
also I mean everything like
it's difficult to do once you are you
are running a play like then you of
course it's like very normally you
should play by hand yeah not by whenever
you every move because you can't then
think about every single move is
difficult it's too labor yeah yeah
guys any questions for Vladimir no just
uh our congratulations uh Vladimir keep
up good work can I
can I have you lost because you
blundered you have so many titles you
won so many championships in your life
so I have a question like what do you
recommend players you talked about
having a lot of students what are the
best practices to do when you lose your
first round to get back to the
tournament because you did you have two
out of three so you won the next two
rounds
okay I don't know what to say here yeah
you I mean definitely
losing should not affect your
your play in general and the other
rounds like second round third round
because okay you should forget if it is
possible uh immediately about that of
course happens yeah some accidents
happen and it's normal it's not like he
it was not foreseen so I thought that
okay maybe in the beginning it could be
some problems uh this is what you what
you get this is what out of practice of
course so it should not affect you and
just trying to keep to keep your pace
and playing yeah
this is how I I deal with the situation
perfect thank you so much that's a good
advice because I tend to lose first
round so
make sure how to balance back to your
first round loss uh good luck Vladimir
uh just saying that Zoe